There's a narration reported by
Al-Hafiz ibn Majah Rahimahullah ta'ala
in his book of Sunan.
In this narration, a companion by the
name of Iyad ibn Himar radiyallahu anhu
tells us that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said,
This is a very, very important narration
and
there are many verses of the Quran,
other narrations that
support and
provide a similar meaning.
But this narration really
just kind of
spells it out for us.
Our prophet,
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam,
warned his companions and said,
"Every nation,
meaning every messenger, their nation,
every group of people throughout time,
every nation
has
something that is a particular weakness
to them.
A fitna.
A fitna meaning
something that is particularly
particularly
s- something that will take them off of
the path. Something that is a particular
fitna. There are many fitan,
right? There are many things that would
lead to a person's misguidance.
But there are certain things that are
more prominent in that than others.
Every nation has their weakness.
And the fitna, the weakness of my nation
is money,
wealth,
material things. Al-mal.
Money.
That is the weakness.
I'll give you an example.
Let's take an example.
I I want you to not answer
with your mind.
I want you to answer with your feeling.
What you feel when I ask this question.
Okay?
Let's have a scenario.
Let's say a man
went to the gas station and bought a
scratch-off ticket.
Lottery ticket,
huh?
And they scratched it off. What is this
called? What do we call this in Islam?
Gambling. Is there anyone here who
doubts that this is haram?
So, we all agree, right?
Okay.
He scratches it off.
He bought it for a dollar.
He won $5.
Now, he goes to the cashier. He wants to
cash it in.
He has now turned $1 into five, right?
See idea.
Now, the cashier is going to give him
$5.
Those $5, what are they ruling in Islam?
Mhm?
Haram?
So, the winnings, so the act itself is
haram.
So, the gain and profit behind it is
also what?
Haram. Is there anyone here who doubts
that those winnings are haram?
Okay. So, we're all on the same page,
right?
All right.
Let me change the question. And this is
actually a question
that I've had asked before. This is a
real situation. This is not a a fake you
know, pie-in-the-sky imaginary thing.
These are real things that happen.
So, the feeling you got in your guts, in
your heart,
when you imagine standing in front of
Allah,
and that $5,
anyone here feel that that $5 is haram?
We all feel it is haram, right?
Okay.
Let's say
that person bought that scratch-off
ticket for $1.
And they scratch it off,
and they won $1 million.
Not $5,
$1 million.
What could you do with a a million
dollars?
How much good could you do in the world
with a million dollars? How many wells
could you dig in Africa, and how many
naked Muslims could you clothe, and how
many
a million dollars.
How much did he spend?
$1.
And how much did he win?
$999,999.
That's how much he won.
Don't answer with your mind.
I want you to answer with what you feel
in your gut.
That happened. Where a person came to
you and said, "This happened to me.
Should I go and claim my $1 million?"
What would you answer?
So, this exercise here, this is not a
fake scenario, by the way. This This
This is something that really occurred a
couple years ago with someone that I
know.
But, what gave you pause? What made you
hesitate?
That hesitation.
That feeling of maybe I shouldn't get
involved. Maybe I shouldn't give him a
fatwa. Maybe I shouldn't answer. Or
maybe that feeling in your heart that if
that happened to you,
Allah will forgive him. You know, it's
just $1. I mean, come on, right? And
it's a million dollars, and I'm going to
do a lot of good with it. I'm just going
to keep 100,000. I'm just going to keep
50,000 for myself, pay off my debts, and
the rest I'm going to give in charity.
I'm going to be a good person. I'm going
to just do this one little little little
thing. What changed? What changed
between the scenario of $5 and the
scenario of $1 million? And why did the
ruling perhaps change in your mind? Why
did you not hesitate at $5, but you
hesitated at a million? Why?
What about if it was 10 million?
$100 million.
$1 billion.
Does that change the ruling?
Does that change
the command of Allah and the prohibition
of Allah?
No.
We're answering with our minds, no.
But our body and our heart is screaming,
maybe. Maybe I could find a scholar that
would give me a special fatwa. Maybe I
should look it up online. Maybe I
shouldn't make a decision until I ask.
Maybe I should make istikhara. That's
the meaning of the narration.
Every nation has a weakness and the
weakness of my nation is what?
Money.
That hesitation that you felt in your
toes,
that is why we are where we are today as
a Muslims.
And that is what we have to correct in
order to advance.
Our forefathers, the companions of the
messenger, they didn't have that
hesitation. Is it because they didn't
comfort and and wealth? Is it
because they didn't have the same
feelings you have? Do you love your
children more than they loved their
children?
Or do you have more of a hero complex
than they did? Did none of them think
they were the main character of the
story?
They all knew that before Islam. Every
feeling that you've had, there are
greater men on this earth
with greater faculties and far more
resilience and bigger dreams than you
have. And that didn't give them any more
right to live than you do.
So, the question here is why did we
hesitate and why did the companions
never hesitate?
They would never hesitate. As a matter
of fact, the more the amount went up,
the more sure they would be that that is
haram.
That is how the companions would see a
question that.
A million? Now it's definitely haram.
10 million? Now it is There is no way.
I would rather take the $5 than the 1
million or 10 million or 1 billion or
100 million or whatever it is.
I I know person came to me.
They They made 100
They made $1 million
in gambling.
1 million.
And it was one incident that happened.
And they want They asked me
what what can I do? Look Look at the the
question. What can I do? Not
what should I do? What can I do?
And now my job is what?
To try to squirm and find a loophole for
him so he can get the million. And then,
you know, if you give the masjid a few
dollars here, that wouldn't hurt either,
you know?
Right? And that's exactly how corruption
is. If we have leaders
that have that hesitation, we are
doomed.
We are doomed
as a people.
You want to say something?
I was going to ask
So, in the scenario that
I gave you
earlier, let's say for example
most people would not do this. Somebody
comes to ask for money in your store
and you give them that money
and they went and bought special with
it. You have no idea about it.
Then all of a sudden they find out and
say, "Hey,
brother, the $10 you gave me
I used it on my own and I gave it to
somebody else." You have no knowledge of
it.
How does that apply to you as a Muslim?
Well, if they have it If if you if a
person were to not know
that this these were haram earnings,
and they took it and spent it,
then
there's no blame upon that person if
they don't know, because the neutral
position of wealth is that is
permissible.
Right? But if the person comes and says,
"Hey, remember that money you gave me? I
won a whole bunch of money and here's
your portion." That is categorically
haram.
It's out of doubt.
What if they murdered someone and stole
their money and came to give it to you?
It's haram. The This way and this way is
haram, no matter how you slice it. I'll
give you another scenario.
Would it be permissible
for me to
jump in my car
and give my friend a ride to go buy
drugs?
Does anyone here have doubts about that?
Just I'm being a good guy, you know.
I'm giving them a ride, but he's going
to buy some some drugs.
Would that be permissible?
What about if I were a taxi driver and
he were paying me?
Did you hesitate?
This is the problem that we're talking
about.
Exactly.
And in our minds, we're thinking, "Wait
a minute, this doesn't make sense."
That's exactly what the narration is
speaking about. The only difference
between this and that is introduction of
money into the into the transaction.
That's the only difference between the
two scenarios. Nothing else changed.
The exact parameters and dynamic of the
situation are identical. The only thing
that changed is you're getting paid or
you're not. It's a lot of money or it's
a little bit of money.
It's legal or it's illegal.
If I were to go to a loan shark,
a loan shark, the mafia, okay?
Guy's going to the mafia to get a a
loan, and he's paying compounded 40% APR
interest on that. And if he doesn't,
Bubba's going to come and break his
legs. Is that haram or halal?
Haram, right? We all agree?
What about if it's a company named,
, you know, pay later? Or what about
if it's a company that is approved by
the United States government, and it's
it is permissible because it is
, IFC insured, and this is something
that is permissible. We're going to call
it
we're we're going to call it, , you
know, Vanguard.
They're not a loan shark anymore,
they're Vanguard, okay? And we're not
going to call it compounded interest,
and we're not going to call it a
percentage, or we're not going to call
it a vig. A vig is is, , a street term
for interest. We're going to call it APR
set by the
Federal Reserve. Now, what's the answer
to the question? See, and the only thing
changing between these two scenarios is
money.
That's our weakness, and we have to be
hyper vigilant of that weakness.
Why did the prophet tell us this? Why?
What do we do with it? What do we do
with this information? Why did he use
his precious breath to tell us this? Why
did Allah, from above seven heavens, on
his throne, send his angels to tell his
messenger to spend his time telling us
this piece of information? Why is that
relevant? How do I employ that in my
life? This is where we are.
This is something that we have to think
about, and we have to make sure that we
work this out of our system. The only
way to work it out of your system
is to
reject categorically anything that is
haram. You have to see it through the
lens of the Quran.
If you look at it first and then try to
put the Quran on it, you're going to try
to fit the Quran into the narrative.
It's the opposite. You need to look
through the Quran first and see it.
Anything in this dunya, you need to look
at it from
the perspective of the hereafter,
standing in front of Allah, naked,
barefoot, alone, without a single penny,
standing to be judged in front of Allah.
From that perspective, how would I view
this decision I'm about to make? That is
how the That's the difference
between the companions and the
latter generations. And the idea that we
cannot be those people, we can.
We can. The only thing holding us back
is are these kinds of contraptions that
a shaitan has put up to weaken our
resolve.
[Silence]
What did I tell him?
If maybe it's a little bit halal. What
do you think?
What do you think I told him?
And do you think that he he listened to
me when I told him?
Or do you think he went to someone else
with a bigger hat?
Mhm?
Yeah.
Huh?